worthy Avengers we can bust arms dealers
all the live long day but that up there
that's that's the endgame how are you
guys planning on beating that together
hi everyone it's Charlie hopefully you
guys have had a chance to see Avengers
endgame by now these are gonna be my
Easter eggs from the movie in references
to all the previous MCU movies there
were so many callbacks what I'm gonna do
is is if my video gets way too long past
like 15 minutes I'll just break it in
half and do a part tube because the
movies three hours long of course
there's gonna be a crazy number of
Easter eggs so if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the Marvel videos it's not stopping here
we have spider-man far from home this
summer then we have Comic Con but we'll
probably get our official Marvel phase 4
schedule to learn about exactly what's
coming next even though we have a pretty
good idea we're still doing the Infinity
Gauntlet giveaway to for the next couple
of weeks all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave an Avengers
comment on the video obviously careful
for spoilers if you have not seen
Avengers endgame yet we'll be talking
about very specific stuff so here we go
opening the movie is the Hawkeye scene
where we learn what happened to his
family before the snap or during the
snap wall is happening because while
Hawkeye is teaching his daughter played
by Joe Russo's daughter in real life to
shoot a bow and arrow she's apparently a
chip off the old block because she hits
the bullseye he high-fives her and says
good job Hawkeye which is a reference to
map fractions Hawkeye run where he was
training the Cape Bishop Hawkeye who
also used his name both of them called
each other Hawkeye in really funny
moments throughout the series the song
playing over the opening credits is dear
mr. fantasy they get rescued by Captain
Marvel there were a lot of questions
about the timeline how this worked where
did she come from what about the Captain
Marvel post-credits scene just assume
right after the events of the Captain
Marvel post-credits scene where she
shows up and says where's fury answering
the page she turns right back around to
go to space because they tell her that
Tony is probably stuck on his way home
so she was probably just flying on her
way to Titan looking for him along the
way and just happened to find their ship
they did not do the Stan Lee intro logo
like they did for the Captain Marvel
movie though they just took it back to
the regular Marvel Studios logo when
Ironman comes back he makes a reference
to Avengers age of Ultron in his suit of
armor around the world they
were probably more references to
Avengers age of Ultron that almost any
other movie besides the original
Avengers movie he calls rocket a
build-a-bear and then sort of a bit of
insanity as he starts to go a little bit
nuts because he's been stuck in space
for so long he rips off his arc reactor
slaps it in caps hand and says you put
this on and you hide the interesting
thing about that is that during Marvel
phase four they're doing a what-if comic
book series where it's what if Peggy
Carter had got the Super Soldier Serum
and Steve Rogers had worn an Iron Man
suit built by Howard Stark so a lot of
people were curious why there was no
traditional post-credit scene because
typically Marvel movies will have a
scene at the end of the movie or during
the credits that'll explain what's
coming next but the difference in
Avengers end game is that they put those
scenes during the actual movie so there
are several scenes throughout the movie
that let you know exactly what these
characters are gonna be doing during
phase four it's just that some of those
movies and characters will pop up in the
past not in the future Captain America
being one of them because in the future
he's old man cap now when they go to
kill thanos on his farm rocket is now
official captain of the benatar because
all the other guardians are either gone
or dead and nebula is kind of a half
guardian half Avenger but he doesn't
roll call asking who here has not been
into space Captain America Black Widow
war machine all raised their hands
because within the MCU they are the only
ones in here that have never been to
outer space he says none of you better
throw up on my ship then when they get
to his farm you see the Scarecrow from
the comics and in the end of the
Infinity Gauntlet comic book storyline
he had become a farmer so that's what
he's doing here the work is done but
Thor goes for the heads second time
around
so they killed fan OHS within the first
10 to 15 minutes of the movie there's a
five-year time jump and you get a cameo
from Joe Russo one of the directors
playing one of the survivors in Captain
America's grief counseling group one of
the other cameos is from jim Starlin
creator of Thanos in the comics and a
couple other big cosmic characters that
will probably see during phase 4 the
Easter Egg for Captain America here is
these sort of taken over Falcons job
because this is kind of what Falcon did
back during Winter Soldier it's a
five-year time jump so you're jumping
around finding out what everyone's like
five years later but you finally pick up
with ant-man that rat that helped him
get out of the quantum realm is probably
the true hero of the movie you get a
cameo from Kenji
there were a couple community cameos
there's so many community people that
have cameoed in the MCU now but Ken Jong
was supposed to start during Avengers
infinity war but a scheduling conflict
kept him out the Russos brought him back
during avengers endgame to play the
manager of the warehouse where Scott
Lang's van has been this whole time the
other community cameo was Yvette Nicole
Brown who played a secretary in the
1970s shield base from Winter Soldier
where they were going to get the Pym
particles you get a very big name or
teaser when we go back to the Avengers
base when Black Widow is still liaison
with the other surviving Avengers around
the world keeping tabs on everything
that's happened Okoye says that near
Wakanda there was an underwater
earthquake incident she says we handle
it by not handling it because it's an
underwater earthquake that is probably
the biggest name war teaser for Marvel
phase 4 that they could have done yes
because of a rights issue they can't do
a name war solo movie quite as easily
it's the same situation with the Hulk
movies can't quite do it because
Universal has the rights but they can
still use the name or character in other
people's movies so maybe appearance
during Black Panther 2 but Captain
Marvel is wearing a different darker
blue and red costume from the comics and
she has her short haircut from the
comics too a lot of people were
wondering why her hair was different
they were just doing a comic book thing
she's still a police increased role
space during that five year span because
remember everywhere around the universe
every planet had 50% of all life erased
Hawkeye becomes Ronan and goes around
killing criminals that survive the snap
rocky gets his blue costume from the
guardians of the galaxy comics from the
annihilation conquest storyline when
that first team from the MCU originally
formed in the comics Ironman has gotten
married to Pepper Potts he's living in
nature in a cabin with a little bit of
technology they've had a daughter named
Morgan Stark which is a reference to an
uncle of Tony's in the comics who's
actually a villain she comes out of her
tent in the yard wearing Pepper Potts
rescue armor from the comics that's
right Pepper Potts gets her full rescue
armor that she wears much later in the
film during the big third act battle he
jokes that mommy never wears the things
that I buy for her but they're also
winking at the fact that she Morgan
Stark might at some day become one of
the Young Avengers and take up his
mantle as Iron Man or Iron Heart or
whatever you want to call her just
remember that because of what happened
to Tony Stark she is now he
his heir apparent so that eventually
when she's a teenager in old enough say
like the same age as Scott Lang's
daughter who's a teenager now she's old
enough to join the Young Avengers and
actually start wearing some of that gear
because he says you like to go into the
garage oh I found it you weren't looking
for this
oh well daddy likes to go into the
garage too which at this point in his
life is sort of a low five version of
his original basement where I used to
tinker with all of his gear there were a
lot of people that claim that they saw
x-men names on the memorials as ant-man
is walking around to the Presidio near
the San Francisco bridge trying to find
out whether or not his family names are
on there I could not find any x-men
names but it makes sense that they
wouldn't put any on there because the
movie was made before the Fox Disney
deal was done so they couldn't include
any traditional x-men stuff but when he
goes back to his house to look for
Cassie he finds her she's a teenager now
and because the movie ends five years in
the future in 2023 when they do the
ant-man in the wasp sequel presumably
she'll still be a teenager and will be
able to participate in things I lost
stature from the comics because there's
a version of Cassie Lange once she
becomes a teenager who joins the Young
Avengers in acts a little bit like
ant-man does becoming giant woman so to
speak they call her stature but she has
the same abilities as Ant Man in the
comics there was a lot of young avengers
teasing going on during this there have
been rumors that they're working on a
young Avengers movie for a long time but
nothing official from Marvel has been
said they go to Tony to try and get his
help they make a bunch of Back to the
Future jokes your plant isn't based on
back to the future is it Tony references
the vision he had during age of Ultron I
didn't want to think it was real but now
it seems like it was the thing is is
that during the third act battle with a
nose you actually see Captain America
she'll get cracked by thanasis sword
it almost winds up looking exactly like
his vision albeit with the big twist
because they wind up winning the day
they talk about Doctor Strange he calls
him the Bleecker Street magician because
Doctor Strange lives on Bleecker Street
there were actually ballet shoes on
black widows desk after that five years
later time jump remember she was a
ballerina in the age of Ultron
flashbacks we still have to learn a lot
about her backstory that's what the
Black Widow prequel movie is probably
gonna tell us they go to find hope
because they need a big brain to help
them figure out time travel and he's
become Professor Hulk bit disappointing
that we didn't get to see that happen
but the way that Banner explains it is
that about 18 months after the snap he
goes to a gamma lab and messes with
himself in the Hulk a little bit more
and that's how he became professor Holt
so he did more gamma experiments about
18 months after the snap and for those
of you that are wondering yes he can
still go back to being banner if he
wants but the whole idea that he
explains in the diner while he's wolfing
down all that food and taking selfies
with the kids is that he thinks the Hulk
is the answer now not the problem so he
likes the Hulk so he doesn't want to go
back to just being Banner professor Hulk
of course big comic book Easter Egg
there was a long run where he was a more
chatty intelligent version of banner
with the body of the Hulk just the best
of both worlds as he says during the
movie the mind of banner in the body of
the Hulk when they're first
experimenting with time travel using the
van before Iron Man comes back they have
to use Hank Pimm's quantum suit from
ant-man the wasp they make the white
suits and they have to test it out
Hawkeye volunteers they make a couple of
jokes about time-travel movies they say
a wrinkle in time Bill & Ted's Excellent
Adventure time after time Terminator
time cop Hot Tub Time Machine and even
though it's not a time-travel film Iron
Man calls fat Thor Lebowski so the funny
thing about a couple of those references
are is is that there are other MCU
actors in this movie in another big MCU
movies that starred in the movies that
they reference so Lebowski was played by
Jeff Bridges who was Obadiah Stane
nobody makes a reference to it's a
Lebowski looks an awful lot like that
Obadiah Stane guy and Sebastian Stan was
the villain of Hot Tub Time Machine
obviously nobody makes a reference to
that either but the rules of time-travel
that the MCU writers went with when they
were writing Avengers in game were
basically Dragon Ball Z rules you can't
do anything in the past to change your
future the future that you come back to
will always be the same what happens is
is when you change the past you're only
creating alternate realities alternate
timelines so even though they take the
Infinity stones back to where they stole
them from to prevent that from happening
there's still a couple of loose ends
like the Loki that got away with the
tesseract so there's a very big
alternate timeline shooting out from
2012 there were a couple other moments
like that so there still are some
alternate timelines that they
inadvertently create when Professor Hulk
in rocket go to new Asgard to pick Thor
up new Asgard is in the place where Odin
old door to put it on the cliffside of
Norway Valkyrie comes back for a cameo
there are only a few Asgardians left
because remember only about half escape
from Thor ship before Thanos blew
everyone up then half of those that
survived got snapped so their way down
but Thor has completely gone PTSD and is
trying to ignore everything into a
reality he's got this giant beer belly
he's living with Corrigan meek playing
fortnight they even include gameplay
from fortnight in the movie I don't know
if that was a paid integration or if
there's just a reference because
fortnight in real life does a lot of
infinity war Avengers tie-ins like they
did the Thanos with the gauntlet last
year but in the comics new Asgard was
actually inside Oklahoma so this is just
their version of comic book new asgaard
on planet earth remember the ice cream
from Infinity Ward the Hulk of hooker
burnin fudge stark raving hazelnuts
during the time-travel sequence when
they're trying to figure things out
professor Hulk is actually eating some
of his ice cream Hoka Hoka burnin fudge
when they finished constructing the
time-travel platform when they're all in
the white suits you noticed that the
design as they're staring down at it is
the exact same design as Iron Man's
original arc reactor that Pepper gave
him proof that Tony Stark has a heart
that is not a coincidence because they
bring that arc reactor back during his
funeral at the end of the film so was
just another very cool Easter Egg in
reference to the original Iron Man movie
one of the more important touchstones
for avengers endgame that he kept
calling back to because of the very
notable I am Iron Man moment at the end
of the film because Ant Man doesn't know
anything about the Infinity stones they
have to launch into a giant explainer
while they're figuring out where they're
gonna send all the teams back to Thor
launches into a big explainer for Thor
the dark world trying to explain the
plot of that film to them but the three
different times they go back to our 2012
the Battle of New York during the
original Avengers movie because there
are three Infinity stones because they
have the time stone with the ancient one
who's still alive because it's five
years before Doctor Strange becomes
Doctor Strange sorcerer supreme they
have the mine stone because of Loki and
his scepter and the tesseract of the
space stone Black Widow and Hawkeye go
to Vermeer to get the soul stone before
the events of infinity war the nebula
and war machine go to Morag before the
events of the guardians of the galaxy
movie so they can get the Power Stone
before Peter quill gets it the shuttle
lotta new footage for some of these
things particularly the Battle of New
York because they're trying to steal the
stones from the end of the original
Avengers movie so they've already taken
down Loki they're putting him in
captivity they bring back cameos from a
Robert Redford who's playing his
character they bring back every one from
that Winter Soldier elevator scene does
anyone want to get off here but cap says
hail Hydra which is actually a reference
to Hydra cap and obviously all the hail
hydras that happen during the Winter
Soldier movie they shot a new scene for
that other elevator scene when they make
Hulk take the stairs so many stairs
apparently 2012 Ironman wears Axe body
spray you can make fun of him all you
want to for that but while they're
trying to get the tesseract Hoek busts
out because so many stairs he's pissed
off the tesseract gets into the hands of
Loki from 2012 who takes it in escapes
off to who knows where but remember our
version of Loki from infinity war is
still dead so if we see this Loki come
back and interact with other characters
in present days say during as guardians
of the galaxy vol 3 because that's kind
of what that movie is now then it'll be
the alternate reality version of Loki it
won't be Thor's Loki from his original
timeline Captain America fights himself
from 2012 who's a little bit more of a
do-gooder he hasn't been through the
events at Winter Soldier he's not quite
as jaded 2012 cap gives and that I can
do this all day reference our cap goes
yeah yeah I know I got it they pretty
much fight each other to a standstill
but our cap gets young cap by saying
Bucky's still alive because this is
before the events of Winter Soldier so
young cap has no idea what's going on
then when he's walking away he looks at
himself who's kind of flipped over and
says that really is America's ass is it
a callback to ant-man's quote from
earlier in the film then I think what
I'm gonna do is is I'm gonna call time
on this video because it's sort of he
gets super long and I'll pick up part 2
of my Easter eggs with what happens when
they go back to the 1970s so just look
out for my part to Easter Egg just
continuing on in the film like I said
the movies 3 hours long so there's a
crazy number of Easter eggs while you
wait for everything click here for my
video on the ending in that special
little moment during the end credits
scene and click here for my brand new
Game of Thrones season 8 episode 4
trailer video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I love
three thousand
[Music]